prévisions pour l'année 1968 pour l'emmy
devenir 168 je vois un début d'année
vraiment calme voyez dans les affaires
et et bien moi pour bordeaux je pourrais
vous dire que des événements assez pour
importants peuvent se dérouler en 68 vu
du côté financier et du côté économique
comme vous le dites si bien
bon eh bien moi je le vend mieux que
l'année passée je vois à partir du mois
d'avril les affaires vont reprendre que
des ouvriers
il y aura beaucoup de mouvement dans la
france entière de toute façon et pour
bordeaux également assez de grève ça
c'est une chose à ne pas éviter l'année
68 davantage de travail dans le bâtiment
comment vous dire on va faire davantage
de maisons m'excuser si je parle pas
remis de france est davantage de leurs
remarques et je trouve qu'il y aura
moins de chômage les meurtres ne vous
intéresse pas nos wii des inondations un
peu à quel endroit du côté de la
dordogne et comme est bien plutôt à
l'hiver c'est à dire willy au
commencement de l'hiver les événements
que les événements heureux je vois dans
bordeaux autres je vois vraiment tout
s'arrange de tout va s'arranger je vois
pour vraiment bourse en mai lire et non
pas ce que vous voyez des mariages
inattendue par exemple voilà l'événement
oui oui je vois un mariage kim acquise
par le radar le mans
entier dans notre ajoutant notre région
nous allons avoir un grand chanteur
inconnu qui va devenir mondial et qui va
passer à la télévision sera dans notre
région eu à me chanter ooh mondialement
connue oui il sera certainement bordeaux
les loyers ça sera peut-être le premier
qui sera madame télé joue à me poser une
dernière question est ce que jean claude
et il va se marier cette année et bien
et régulier romain il aurait déjà dû
peut-être se marier il va se marier mais
il ya un petit retard d'un mariage mais
c'est malika même moi je vois cette
année 68
[Musique]